on december 29 2010 everyone in iowa was
on the edge of their seats waiting for
the hot lotto drawing the grand prize
was up to 16.5 million dollars if you
want even after the greedy government
takes their cut in the form of taxes it
is still life-changing money and even
though the chances of winning were only
1 in 11 million you have a higher chance
of dying in a plane crash hey you never
know but that night someone had actually
done it they won the whole thing the
mystery winner had managed to match
every number right down to the bonus
number 3 12 16 26 33 and 11 a 1 in 11
million chance local news headlines
became flooded with the stories about
the 16.5 million dollar winner that
lucky son of butt but there was this one
problem the winner wasn't coming forward
most people who find out they just
became an overnight millionaire would
claim their money as quickly as possible
but strangely enough no one showed up
with a winning ticket every day the iowa
lottery told people to double check
their tickets because someone had just
become filthy rich well it's been almost
a month since we had announced that we
had a hot lotto 16.5 million dollar hot
lotto winner the iowa lottery
has been looking and and asking for
everyone to please check their tickets
and as a ceo i wanted to announce that i
believe that the
person who has purchased or owns this
ticket
we believe
probably doesn't know that they have it
but slowly as the days turn into months
no one came to claim their fortune of
course some people tried to claim the
money some claimed they won but their
ticket had been lost or stolen others
even tried to say those exact numbers
were the lucky numbers of their friend
who had just died in a car accident and
that golden ticket must have been in the
car with them no matter what they tried
the lottery officials would tell them
the same thing every single time if they
didn't have the exact 15 digit serial
number on the back of the winning ticket
they were not gonna get the money
oh come on
almost a full year went by and the
winner still didn't show their face and
the thing about this lottery ticket is
that it was only valid for one year so
time was running out if the lottery was
going to claim their millions they would
have to do it real quick and that's when
they got the call a man named philip
johnson said that he was a 16.5 million
dollar winner and he had the 15 digit
serial number on the back of the ticket
to prove it the only strange thing was
that he said he was living in canada at
the time and that he was too sick to
pick up his winnings so he wanted the
money to be sent to him instead
unfortunately for him iowa doesn't allow
people to claim lottery prices without
showing up in person no matter the
circumstances and wasn't the story just
a little bit too good to be true the
mystery winner shows up days before the
ticket expires and claims he was too
sick for an entire year to come pick up
the 16.5 million dollars the lottery
official started getting really
suspicious so she decided to give the
caller a little test unbeknownst to the
public the iowa lottery actually had
cctv footage of the winner buying the
ticket at a quick trip gas station in
des moines so she asked him a simple
question what did he wear the day he
bought the million dollar ticket his
answer wasn't even close so they refused
to give him the price but they never
forgot the strange incidents you see
philip johnson the wannabe lottery
winner later confessed that a
businessman named robert rhodes had
asked him to clean the ticket for him
but even rhodes said he had nothing to
do with it then just two hours before
the ticket expires two lawyers showed up
in person at the iowa lottery office
holding the winning tickets the lorry
said they were there to pick up the
prize on behalf of their anonymous
client the client requested the money to
be paid to hexim investments which
turned out to be owned by none other
than philip johnston the man who tried
to claim the price over the phone a
month earlier again the officials
refused and now they were more
suspicious than ever who had really
bought that ticket it would take them
another two years to find out and what
they uncovered ended up being more
shocking than they could have ever
imagined my name is jake tran and we
make documentaries on money power war
and crime so that you can see the world
for what it really is a giant game of
acquiring power you can't get out of
this game either way so instead of being
a victim why not learn to be a better
player
your parents teachers friends society
will never teach you any of this so
we're going to
stay dangerous and this is the biggest
lottery fraud in american history
[Music]
lotteries are predatory they play on our
psychology to suck a stride of our
hard-earned money but what if lottery
psychology could be used for good what
if lottery psychology could be used to
incentivize you to save money and build
wealth instead of keeping you poor well
that is where yada comes in yada is the
future of savings accounts it's a high
interest fdic insured savings account
meaning that the government guarantees
your money up to 250 000
just like any other savings account but
the real game changer is that yada
incentivizes you to save more by paying
you interest in prizes and because they
set it up this way you not only get the
protections of a regular boring savings
account but you also get the chance to
win 10 million dollars every single week
the more money you save the higher your
chances of winning that's why yada calls
it a no-lose lottery and your chances of
winning is actually pretty high every
single week around 40 of users win a
prize on average and yadda has already
paid out over 9 million dollars in
prizes like crystal catherine and leanne
who all won nearly 40 000 each or
frankie and mark who both won a tesla
model 3. all you have to do is click the
link below to sign up then you deposit
as little as 25 into your account and
with every 25 dollars you put in you
earn one ticket every single week so a
100 deposit equals four tickets every
week you gotta draw seven randomly
generated numbers and depending on how
many numbers you match you can win
anywhere from 10 cents to 10 million
dollars and what's great is that you
literally can't lose they set it up in a
way where users earn 1.5 percent on
average and your fdic insured accounts
even if you don't win any of the big
prizes which is already way higher than
other savings accounts plus your account
is protected by bank grade encryption
and i'm friends with the founders
they're great guys
literally everyone should be using yada
and the more time you waste not using
yada the more money you're losing out on
so start using the future of savings
accounts by pausing the video and
clicking the link below to sign up click
the link below to play the no lose
lottery now thanks to yada for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
with so many people using every trick in
the book to get their hands on the 16.5
million dollars the iowa division of
criminal investigation and the attorney
general decided to get involved they
were going to solve the mystery once and
for all and the easiest way to do that
would be to release all the evidence
they had to the public including the
cctv video of the winner and it didn't
take long for the video to go viral
this afternoon we're releasing the
surveillance video from the kwik trip
store where the hot lotto ticket was
purchased in december of 2010. the cctv
video of the mystery ticket buyer got so
popular that it eventually landed in the
lap of ed stefan an employee of the
multi-state lottery association also
known as musl the moment he heard the
voice in the video it hit him like a ton
of bricks
he knew who it was
he knew who had bought the winning
ticket
it was eddie tipton head of i.t security
for the musl aka the guy who was in
charge of keeping the lottery fair and
secure for multiple states and games
including hot lotto to be sure stefan
played the audio for another colleague
without showing her the video almost
immediately the co-worker asked quote
why am i listening to a tape of eddie
talking end quote and if that wasn't
enough one of eddie tipton's good
friends and colleagues heard the voice
and swore it was him but before ed
stefan reported eddie he had to be
absolutely positive so he used audio
software to remove all the other noise
from the audio except the buyer's voice
and compared it to a video of eddie
talking then he went to the actual
quiktrip store where the winning ticket
was purchased to measure the height of
the shelves and width of the tiles to
match it against eddie's size
he was hoping that he was dead wrong
that his co-worker wasn't the man in the
tape he wanted all his research to
exonerate eddie but instead it was the
nail in his coffin there was no doubt
about it the man buying the winning
ticket in the video was eddie tipton as
a musl employee it was illegal for eddie
to participate in any lottery game at
first they assumed that's why he tried
so hard to get other people to claim the
winning ticket for him but then they
started doing a little digging and
things got confusing
eddie tipton had been working at the
musl for years he did things like create
software and install security systems
onto musl computers a big part of his
job was reviewing security for different
lottery games around the country and
coding the program that picks the random
numbers of the lottery jackpot eddie
worked to run 60 hours per week and
earned 100k per year
the weird thing was that he managed to
buy a brand new house for over half a
million dollars all by himself that
didn't really match his budget and when
they brought eddie in for questioning he
swore he wasn't the mystery ticket buyer
he insisted that he wasn't even in the
state of iowa on the day the ticket was
purchased but his phone records told a
different story not only did his phone
place him in iowa on the day the ticket
was bought it also showed that he spoke
to none other than businessman robert
rhodes for 71 minutes on the same night
you remember him right the guy that
asked the other guy to claim the ticket
for him it didn't take police long to
discover that robert rose and eddie
tipton were actually best friends they
even took vacations together that's how
close they were
slowly the picture was coming together
and police were now 100 sure that eddie
tipton had somehow rigged the lottery to
win they just didn't know how so they
arrested eddie tipton and charged him
with two counts of fraud one for trying
to fraudulently claim the winning ticket
and one for manipulating the lottery to
win
the jury didn't care that it was all
circumstantial evidence they were just
as convinced as the prosecutors that
eddie did it
and on july 20th 2015 he was found
guilty and sentenced to 10 years in
prison eddie quickly appealed and
remained free on bail everyone involved
thought that would be the end of the
story
little did they know
it was only the beginning
[Music]
the prosecutors offered eddie tipton
plea deal after plea deal to tell them
how he rigged the lottery but he
wouldn't talk they were just about to
cut their losses and move on when they
received a strange anonymous tip
all the callers said was quote hey do
you all know eddie tipton's brother won
the lottery about 10 years ago somewhere
west maybe colorado end quote
and just like that the case crossed
state lines what was one isolated case
of fraud suddenly started unraveling
into something much bigger
first they found that eddie's brother
tommy had won over a 550k jackpot prize
in the colorado lottery in 2005. one of
tommy's friends said he actually tried
to trade him the new dollar bills for
crumpled old ones after winning
that raised some red flags so the fbi
brought him in for an interview but
tommy managed to explain it away by
telling them that he was hiding the
winnings from his wife amidst a bitter
divorce
they couldn't see any reason not to
believe him but then the plot thickened
it turned out that two years later
somebody had won over 780 k dollars in
the wisconsin lottery and those winnings
were paid out to a company and that
company was owned by none other than mr
robert rhodes eddie's best friend then
on november 23 2011 a year after the
iowa lottery winning a man named kyle
kahn claimed a prize of 1.2 million
dollars in the oklahoma lottery but he
wasn't a regular lottery player either
and he specifically picked his own
numbers instead of having them randomly
generated
when eddie tipton's phone wreckers were
investigated it showed he had kyle
khan's number in his contacts the deeper
investigators looked the more lottery
winners they found in eddie tipton's
phone contacts and many of them didn't
even know they were committing a crime
they thought they were just playing
eddie's lucky numbers for him or picking
up the prize because he couldn't play
with his job title they were just pawns
in eddie's game
and the longer he got away with it the
more brazen eddie became
at one point in the investigation anyone
who'd won the lottery anywhere looked
suspicious because anyone could have
gotten information from or have been
helping eddie but even with all this
evidence showing that eddie was running
a multi-state lottery rigging scheme
they still couldn't figure out how he
pulled it off
that was until 2017 when the truth
behind his master plan came to light
[Music]
the fbi finally found what they were
looking for they were investigating the
random number generator used to pick the
winning numbers for wisconsin's lottery
here's how it worked for educational
purposes only nothing more
step one become an expert at coding and
get a job at the lottery association
the reason tipton could pull off such an
incredible scheme was because of his job
it gave him the access he needed to rig
the system from the inside step 2 get
probability on your side the chance of
winning the lottery is practically next
to impossible that's why you'll have to
improve your luck with a few lines of
clever code but you can't just go in and
make it super obvious that you change
the random number generators code to win
on certain numbers
so you give the random number generator
a particular set of conditions for
winning that nobody would ever notice
on wednesdays and saturdays that landed
on may 27th november 22nd or december
29th if the drawing was after 8pm the
range of possible number combos the
generator could pick dropped
significantly
so at these precise times the odds of
winning go from around 1 1-5 million to
1 in 200 if you knew the magic numbers
step 3 sit back and wait for your lucky
day
when the day comes play your lucky
numbers and get ready to win some money
maybe you'd win a few thousand maybe a
few hundred thousand and if you were
really lucky that day like eddie tipton
was back in 2010 you could walk away
with the grand prize it's that easy
once investigators found the code and
realized how eddie pulled it off he
finally agreed to tell them everything
eddie said he didn't mean to create the
biggest lottery fraud in history it just
kind of happened one day at work a
co-worker jokingly asked him if he put
any special numbers in the generator
since he's the one who wrote the
software and that's when he got the idea
at first he just did it to see if it
would work and if he could get away with
it he tampered with a security camera so
that nobody could see what he was doing
and installed some self-deleting
software code that would allow him to
hypothetically predict the winning lotto
numbers on certain days then he waited
until november 23 2005 when his brother
tommy tipton won his first big jackpot
after that eddie just couldn't stop
winning was just too addictive
eddie saw himself as a sort of lottery
robin hood
he insisted it was basically his
responsibility to use his newfound gift
and help the people around him taking
money from the greedy government and
giving it back to the people a noble
pursuit so he would give winning numbers
to people like his brother and robert
rhodes but as much as eddie wanted to be
the good guy investigators had a
different opinion of him
i regret my actions i'm sorry for the
people i heard
[Music]
on july 12 2017 eddie pled guilty to
theft by fraud and computer crime in the
end he admitted to defrauding the united
states out of over 24 million dollars
including the 16.5 million dollars that
he never got the chance to claim
he rigged lottery's games in iowa
colorado wisconsin kansas and oklahoma
for his crimes eddie was sentenced to 25
years in prison but in reality only a
few weeks before the release of the
video you're watching right now eddie
got out on parole after serving only
five years he was actually supposed to
get out in february 2022 but his parole
was postponed after he got into a fight
with a fellow inmate and all his
co-conspirators his brother tommy tipton
was sent to jail for 75 days
philip johnston the man who initially
tried to claim the ticket entered an
agreement with the state of iowa that
protected him from any charges it's
believed that he didn't know exactly
what he was participating in and robert
rhodes ended up getting six months of
house arrest after he agreed to testify
against eddie
and all the money well most of it is
gone
eddie and tommy spend the majority of
their legal winnings on lawyers and real
estate most of which is conveniently now
owned by their mother lawanda tipton
tommy and eddie were ordered to pay over
2 million dollars in restitution for
their crimes and even though they own
nearly 2 million dollars in property the
tipton brothers have paid less than one
thousand three hundred dollars since
their conviction so as it turns out
eddie tipton did actually get away with
hacking the lottery
so learn from eddie
if you're gonna do anything remotely
sketchy at all small simple things like
your phone records could be the death of
you
and don't forget if you want a chance at
actually winning some money up to 10
million dollars while building your
wealth at the same time you've got to
sign up for yada the future of savings
accounts with yada your money is
guaranteed by the government up to 250
000 just like any other savings account
but they took all this effective lottery
psychology to incentivize you to save
money instead of wasting it on lotteries
i've met the founders they're great guys
and have already won some money with
them after depositing money in yatta for
only like a week or two it's a really
cool app and company and remember you
can't lose compared to other government
lotteries they set it up in a way where
users earn 1.5 percent on average in
your fdic insured accounts which is
already way higher than other savings
accounts literally everyone should be
using yada and the more time you waste
not using yada the more money you're
losing out on so start using the future
of savings accounts by pausing the video
and clicking the link below to sign up
click the link below to play the no lose
lottery now thanks again to yada for
sponsoring this video
hope you guys enjoyed the video and if
you're new here my name is jake and this
is one of the biggest channels on
youtube for documentaries on money power
war and crime so make sure you click the
subscribe button below you can follow me
on instagram jake tran for a chance to
win a thousand dollars and you can
follow me on facebook too if you want
shorter versions of these videos but
that's going to wrap it up stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
you